what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the various types of
discontinuities that you've probably
seen when you took algebra or
precalculus but then relate it to our
understanding of both two-sided limits
and one-sided limits
so let's first review the classification
of discontinuities
so here on the left you see that this
curve looks just like y equals x squared
until we get to x equals 3 and instead
of it being 3 squared it does at this
point you have this opening and instead
the function at 3 is defined at 4 but
then it keeps going it looks just like y
equals x squared
this is known as a point
or a removable discontinuity
and it's called that for obvious reasons
you're discontinuous at that point you
might imagine of defining or redefining
the function at that point so it is
continuous so the discontinuity is
removable but then how does this relate
to our definition of continuity well
let's remind ourselves our definition of
continuity we say f is continuous
continue us
if and only if or let me write f
continuous
at
x equals c if and only if the limit
as x approaches c
of f of x
is equal to the actual value of the
function when x is equal to c
so why does this one fail
well the two-sided limit actually exists
you could find if we say c in this case
is 3
the limit
as x approaches
3 of f of x
it looks like if you graphically inspect
this and i actually know this is the
graph of y equals x squared except at
that discontinuity right over there this
is equal to
but the issue is is the way this graph
has been depicted this is not the same
thing as the value of the function this
function
f of 3 the way it's been graphed f of 3
is equal to 4.
so this is a situation where this
two-sided limit exists but it's not
equal to the value of that function you
might see other circumstances where the
function isn't even defined there so
that isn't even there
and so once again the limit might exist
but the function might not be defined
there so in either case you aren't going
to meet this criteria for continuity and
so that's how a point or removable
discontinuity why it is discontinuous
with regards to our limit definition of
continuity
so now let's look at this a second
example if we looked at our intuitive
continuity test if we were just trying
to trace this thing
we see that once we get to x equals 2 i
have to pick up my pencil to keep
tracing it and so that's a pretty good
sign that we are discontinuous
we see that
over here as well if i'm tracing this
function i got to pick up my pencil to i
can't go through that pointer if i have
to jump down here and then keep going
right over there so in either case i
have to pick up my pencil and so
intuitively it is discontinuous
but this particular type of
discontinuity where i'm making a jump
from one point and then i'm making a
jump down here to continue it is
intuitively called a jump
discontinuity
discontinue
and this is of course a point removable
discontinuity
and so how does this relate to limits
well here the left and right handed
limits exist but they're not the same
thing so you don't have a two-sided
limit so for example for this one in
particular but from
for all the x values up to and including
x equals 2 this is the graph of y equals
x squared and then for x greater than 2
it's the graph of square root of x
so in this scenario if you were to take
the limit
of f of x
as x approaches
from the left
from the left this is going to be equal
to 4 you're approaching this value and
that actually is the value of the
function but if you were to take the
limit as x approaches 2 from the right
of f of x what is that going to be equal
to well we're approaching from the right
this is actually the square root of x so
it's approaching the square root of 2.
you can't you wouldn't know it's the
square root of two just by looking at
this i don't know that just because when
i when i went onto desmos and defined
the function that's the function that i
used but it's clear even visually that
you're approaching two different values
when you approach from the left then
when you approach from the right so even
though the one-sided limits exist
they're not approaching the same thing
so the two-sided limit doesn't exist and
if the two-sided limit doesn't exist it
for sure cannot be equal to the value of
the function there even if the function
is defined so that's why the jump
discontinuity is failing this test and
once again it's intuitive you're seeing
that hey i gotta jump i gotta pick up my
pencil these two things are not
connected to each other
finally what you see here is when you
learned pre-calculus often known as an
asymptotic discontinuity
asymptotic
discontinuity
and intuitively you have an asymptote
here if you it's a vertical asymptote at
x equals two if i were to try to trace
the graph
from the left i'd be i would just keep
on going in fact i would be doing it
forever because it's it would be it
would be infinitely
it would be unbounded as i get closer
and closer to x equals 2 from the left
and if i get to try to get to x equals 2
from the right once again i get
unbounded up but even if i could and
when i say it's unbounded it goes to
infinity so it's actually impossible and
you know
for a more in immortals lifespan to try
to trace the whole thing but you get the
sense that hey there's no way that i
could draw from here to here without
picking up my pencil and if you want to
relate it to our notion of limits it's
that
both the left and right handed limits
are unbounded so they officially don't
exist so if they don't exist then we
can't meet these conditions so if i were
to say
the limit as x approaches 2 from the
left hand side of f x
we can see that it goes unbounded in the
negative direction you might sometimes
see someone write something like this
negative infinity but that's a little
hand wavy with the math the more correct
way to say it it's just unbounded
unbounded and likewise if we thought
about the limit as x approaches 2 from
the right of f x
it is now unbounded towards positive
infinity so this once again this is also
this is also unbounded and
so because it's unbounded and this limit
does not exist it can't meet these
conditions and so we are going to be
discontinuous so this is a point or
removable discontinuity jump
discontinuity i'm jumping and then we
have these asymptotes a vertical
asymptote this is an asymptotic
discontinuity